All right, folks, I'm going to take a look at the e-mini-micro NASDAQ100 index, and I'll
show you the imbalance we're in here.
This is the initial one.
You can always imagine it could stack up into the second one, which it's really a sense
it just done now.
So that could be a cell.
I'd like to see it come down here first.
I'll outline this as I go.
This is kind of like the end of the road for the drop down before it runs Tuesday's highs.
That's what I'm thinking.
This is FOMC.
I'm with it a few minutes for it to do its initial shakeout.
So this is the end of the race lower.
That's the little checkered flag.
You'll notice I have that, so it's not like me talking after the fact.
So you can see I'm doing everything here.
There's where we're looking for it to drop down in and run out the Tuesday highs that
I was mentioning on my community post.
So in other words, we're looking for it to trade down in there.
Now it could sweep a little bit below that because to the left of that imbalance that
I'm highlighting in turquoise, there's the cell side of the career pool resting just
below it.
But for now, I'm just focusing there.
So it could drop down into that level.
There's a couple of ways to use this information.
You can do a trade here with your demo account, compliance reasons, and look for it to run
out the short-term low and or wait for it to potentially trade up into the higher timeframe
fair value gap.
And the reason why you could potentially wait for that is because it's FOMC.
It has like a knee-jerk reaction, kind of like non-farm payroll.
There's an initial leg, then another leg, then like a fake-out leg, and then a real
setup comes, which is what I'm outlining here in that blue shaded area.
So I'm noticing that it's likely to draw down here, so I'm drawing this out so that we can
see the diagram is dropping, okay?
The idea is to drop down here first, this is the quick move I'm looking for, then to
run through Tuesday's highs.
All right, so it should start dropping in here.
I don't want to see it go too much more than that because that would upset the fair value
gap that is not yet traded into.
I think that's going to be the next real drop.
So right here is where I'm thinking initially.
There's sell-side resting right below that low.
So you could be a short here, and your stop would be right above that most recent green
candle to the left of where we're at now, and you can see there's no replay button being
used here.
The candles are painting, the replay button is dim, it's not even a thing with me.
That's not true now, I did recently in the mentorship video use the replay button, but
it felt awkward and I just wanted to do it just to be funny.
So here is the drop down in here.
Now I can revisit the bottom of that fair value gap and bump it, kind of like a support
resistance idea.
That would be a shorting opportunity if it were to do that, and again this stop would
be placed at the high of the most recent green candle to the left.
Right there, see that?
That's a short right there.
Okay, the market is likely to keep dropping in here.
I'm looking for that little bullseye, that blue bullseye right below that short-term
low.
And that blue line, if you noticed when I first started the recording here, that was
really just an order block.
So it could bounce there a little bit, but ultimately my interest is from where we are
now down into that checkered flag area, and it doesn't look like I've got enough room
so I'm going to probably have to move that over to the right a little bit, and again
the mindset is we're dropping down, even though it really initially just ran the Tuesday
high, but it's done it shallow.
The vocabulary I'm using here is running the Tuesday high, not sweeping the Tuesday high.
Difference between sweeping would be, like what it's done here, that would be a sweep,
it's a real shallow little run above that red line, that's Tuesday's high.
So it swept that, and then we're coming back down, post FOMC.
So kind of like look at this move here we're making, and if it can drop down to that blue
shaded area, it might just, if I'm wrong, it might just go down to that little bullseye
and then run higher from there.
I'm hoping it doesn't do that, I want to see it trade down into that blue shaded area,
the little checkered flag is, because that's like the end of the race for bears.
They get into that, then it should start the real move higher, running Tuesday high.
Sweeping Tuesday's high means it runs right over top of it and it just doesn't look back.
Sweeping is where it just goes above or below a low or a high, you know what I mean?
If we're going to sweep by side, that means it's going to go up a little bit and then
go down and reverse.
If I'm saying we're going to run an old high, or relative equal highs, that means we're
going to run through it and continue.
So that way there's a little bit of an understanding here of what I'm saying when I say that.
I try to pick my words carefully so that way you understand the distinction between
what I'm expecting as a sweep and reverse back into the range or expansion move where
I think if we can get down here, and I'm going to scrub this over here because you can see
we're running out of space here, it might take a little bit more candles than I first
thought.
Oh, let me get this back here, there we are, oh, there it is.
This thing, I'm telling you, I look like a noob, ICT's a noob.
All right, so we'll see if we can drop down into that.
And I had to make another video for my mentorship group, so I got to get started on that one.
So here's a bearish order block, you can come back up and hit that and resume going lower.
All right, not bad, not bad.
Let's see if she loves me.
You can see no replay button, everything's dynamic here, all right, about to run into
that cell-side liquidity pool.
Just anchor this here so that we can see visually when it drops below it.
Change the color here, it's a little bit lighter than that one.
Oops, too light, okay, that's good enough that we can see it.
I'll take this off here, all right, and there you go.
I'll come back to this in a moment.
All right, as you can see, the market did in fact trade down, look at the bodies of
the candles respecting that blue shaded area, really, really handsome price delivery.
And it dipped down a little bit below, but that's fine, I'm not worried about being that
accurate.
The main thing is going down into that area, it turns and then runs Tuesday's high.
Look how much more dynamic that is.
Now, what I did was I took the low at the turn after it made its run into that little
blue shaded area.
Once it started rallying and it took out the swing high around that $13,150, basically
crossed back over where the fair value gap is, the larger one that it dropped down into.
Once it trades above that, then I'm going to use the high initially at the two o'clock
hour down to the low post $230.
That range I'm using the Fibonacci to expand up to a target and it came up to $13,437 even.
I'm just waiting for it to hit that and then once it does, then I'll go into the Fibonacci
and I'll show you what this looked like, how I measured it and all that.
Hopefully you can see that it's done the majority of the move, which was outlined on
the community tab before I actually did the video.
I did the video here, you know, marking it up that way you can see it wasn't a replay
thing, it wasn't something after the fact.
It's something that I'm teaching you all here.
Now, the question mark at the bottom lower left-hand corner, what that is anchoring is
the high that was formed at two o'clock or what would be shown as $1400 here on the chart
down to that low where the question mark is.
What you're doing is you're going to get measurement of the range.
Where's 50% of that?
Below 50% is where that fair value gap is that's in turquoise.
That's the targets dropping down into it.
It's a matter of looking at this.
Again, really there's technically, oh there's one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
There's eight trades in this whole entire thing.
So once it trades this level here, I'm looking forward to hit that and then I'll go in and
kind of like show you some things about what I'm referring to as the eight setups.
And this might not be the real setup that you would be looking for.
It might be something, one of the eight that I'll show you.
But that's the unique idea that I want you to adopt as a student of mine.
I don't want you all thinking, well we all have to have the same setup.
No, you don't have to have the same setup.
In fact, you're not.
You're going to come to the conclusion that the things that you're looking for are going
to be much more important when it's uniquely selected, not me pushing you into a mode
saying this is how it's going to work every single time just for you because it's not
going to work that way.
So you have to find a way to grow comfortable with the concepts and how that applies to
the present market conditions and how you select your setup.
And I'll show you eight of them in here.
That way you'll know that this is what you're looking for and it fits your criteria.
And you may not take any of the other seven out of the eight.
But the main one here is obviously the one I highlighted.
It's the one that is the highest form of analysis that we can see exactly where it's going to
draw to before it turns around.
So you can couple what I've shown you here with what I outright came and told you basically
that I'm looking for the drop down at FOMC at 2 o'clock.
Once it drops down into that, usually around 2.30, it's finished its initial leg where
it prices in whatever it's going to do, either high or low, and then starts to rally.
So you can see it's pretty much close to that in terms of algorithmic delivery.
Just a little bit past 2.30.
We're about ready to hit that target here.
And there she is.
All right.
So let's dim that out and I'll take you over to the fib portion and I'll explain everything
to you that way.
All right.
So now obviously I'm going to take you back in.
I'm going to use the fib here.
And what I'm doing is anchoring it to the high down to the low.
Now this is the most extreme.
Now usually I'll use the highest open or close and the lowest open or close in the price
swing when it's not expected to have a whole lot of volatility.
Because it's the FOMC, it's more likely to be much more volatile.
That means the extreme of the ranges should be considered.
That means now I'm going to use the wicks.
You get asked a lot all the time in the comments, like, why does ITC use the wicks and why does
he use the bodies and when does he differentiate?
I just taught you.
OK.
So I'll show you two forms of that.
And actually I'll do this backwards too.
I'm going to draw it from the low up to the high.
I'm looking for upside objectives.
OK.
So low up to high.
Here's one objective.
Here's two objectives.
And now we're just falling short of that one.
OK.
So that's kind of the extreme target for me today.
But if you look at the body to body, it'll make a whole lot more sense in a moment.
There's that target I was looking for there in the earlier portion of the recording.
OK.
Fair value gap.
Initial one here drops down, hits the order block, which is that blue line here.
It bounced up into the fair value gap.
This is what I was suggesting.
This is going to be the main one.
So it's a run on liquidity, drop down, start to drop even lower, hit an order block, then
rallies up, hits the fair value gap.
That sets the stage for the decline down into the area I highlighted in advance.
I said this was the end of the road for the Bears.
Starts to rally, comes back down in, rallies once more.
Takes off, takes out Tuesday's high much more meaningfully, and rallies again.
Pulls back into an imbalance here.
After taking our target, and even continues to go higher from there.
OK.
So let's take a look at some of the trades.
You got the run here ahead of FOMC.
That I would not count.
OK.
That's a setup, but that's a gambler's setup.
It's before the FOMC announcement.
So we have the drop down, then the fair value gap here.
So that's trade one.
The return back to the fair value gap here.
That's trade two.
Drops down in below here.
You would close your short if it's a scalp.
Here is a long idea as a scalp to take us up into Basa liquidity resting above this high here.
And then into a fair value gap that sets up the short down into the objective I was looking for.
Now, right away some of you are thinking, man, I'm not Spider-Man.
How do you expect me to take all these trades?
I'm not, folks.
I'm not.
Any one of these things that I'm outlining here could be a specific setup that fits your unique model.
OK.
That meets the criteria that you're looking for.
Then it drops down here.
That's a buy.
And you can trade this here as an order block there.
Rally's up.
And it comes back down into your order block with these two down close candles here.
Because now this is where I said we were going to turn.
And I said that we were going to run Tuesday's highs.
And I sweep them like this.
It's going to run them.
OK.
So we ran right over top of them here.
So it rallies up.
Comes back down in.
Retracement.
Rally's again.
Small little imbalance.
You can be a buyer there.
Rally's.
And again, here.
This is one that I didn't obviously mention or see because I stopped recording as it ran
through here on our objective.
OK.
And I think that is going to be it.
So I don't want you thinking this is an invitation for you to try to trade FOMC or like a non-farm
payroll event.
They're very, very risky.
Extremely risky.
But they're really fun to go back into and study from a hindsight perspective or if you
can watch it live.
It's a wonderful case study that we can look at how liquidity is taken, how it runs to
the other extreme of the range and how it starts to deliver institutional order flow.
All the down close candles should be supporting price as it goes up and running out Tuesday's
high in a much more meaningful manner.
Hopefully you found this one insightful.
Until next time, be safe.